you get mistaken a lot for mr. zach
braff for zach braff that's right nice
so go ahead well just gonna say you if
an hour goes by on Twitter where someone
doesn't mention it I think Twitter's
broken yeah like I go this thing's not
working you know one who said I look
like him and are constantly putting up
photos like like this one this is
nothing new
first of all guys sorry secondly Zach
posted that my wife took that photo and
if you look at that left column it looks
like this swap didn't even happen like
isn't that the same person in the left
column you guys know Face Swap we've
switched our faces but I'll let you
guess who went where cuz I can't tell so
you can't you looking at it can't tell
which ones you don't know who's who
which one is that I don't think my wife
does either yeah
and I had him on the podcast the other
day a couple weeks ago and he would it
was very surreal because he's directly
across from me and I'd ask him a
question and he'd start thinking you
know when you're thinking you kind of
look in the upper left-hand corner of
your eyes I'd be watching his eyes do
that and then I felt like I was thinking
but I wasn't coming to any thoughts it
was like being on mushrooms yeah it was
yeah it was very bendy I couldn't really
make heads or tails of it
you